[Musik]
mitten im tobenden verkehr steht in
stuttgart dieses kunstwerk wichtigster
teil der installation hier drin wuchs
mitten in der großstadt ein kleines
stück unberührter natur
aber die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr nach
dem motto ist das kunst oder kann das
weg holten die städtischen kettensägen
das kommunale gartenbauamt machte tabula
rasa mit dem sanktuarium das garten
kunstwerk wurde dem erdboden
gleichgemacht
das ist jetzt so aussieht nicht mehr
grün gerade stuttgarter april gewesen
sei es traurig dass ich es einfach
gemacht haben ohne irgendwie zu wissen
was das ist was sie da eben zerstören
bürger haben angesichts des städtischen
frevel trauerflor angebracht 1993 schuf
der weltbekannte niederländische
künstler herman de vries im auftrag der
stadt das sogenannte sanktuarium natur
sollte sich spontan innerhalb des zauns
entwickeln
es wurde nichts gepflanzt das grün wuchs
und konnte ungestört 25 jahre lang das
ein berg jetzt von der stadt stuttgart
zerstört wurde empört den 86 jährigen
künstler und er erwartet auf wenigstens
eine entschuldigung und eine sicherheit
auch in der zukunft nehme verschieben
eigentlich sollten die paar quadratmeter
für die ewigkeit sein
hier sollte nie wieder ein mensch den
fuß rein setzen aber grüne unordnung
mitten in der stadt nicht im
schwabenland regelt dies führe zu
unsicherheit entwicklung die antwort ist
erstmal von yoga und ich finde das eine
chance dass er sein kunst was ist hat
die stadt sogar selbst dran geschrieben
den verantwortlichen im stuttgarter
rathaus ist der kahlschlag inzwischen
ausgesprochen peinlich schriftlich heißt
es dass der künstler dies als zerstörung
seines kunstwerks empfindet wein
keinster weise beabsichtigt und bedauern
wir sehr aber kaputt ist kaputt die 25
jahre bringt keiner mehr zurück ich
finde es halt sehr schlecht der
organisation wenn man das nicht weiß was
nach wegschneiden darf und was nicht
man hat gesehen dass was besonderes ist
und jetzt ja ich da eigentlich jetzt
leider nichts mehr
vielleicht denken die herrschaften in 25
jahren dran das sind im und mit dem
rasenmäher kommt aber bis dahin haben
dieses wahrscheinlich wieder vergessen
hoffentlich holt sich die natur den raum
zurück und korrigiert so die zerstörung
des stuttgarter gartenbauamtes dann wäre
die kunst doch stärker als die courante
deutsche bürokratie